H
SO WILL CO CRAING DOWN
TER T MIDTERM HER NOW WITHRETIOB
TH MOS TIMY BOOK HEADING
INTO THE MTERMANY BIG
CONTRIBUTOR A FORREWSVING
NEWT GINGRICH.
YOU WT TOHINA WHAT YEA DID
YOU GO T CHINA?
YO WERE SPEAKER  THEIME
RREC
>>97.
IENT TO CHINA D TWAN.>> Hanni: I
TO AA AND IF IEMEMBER
RRECTLY IHINK YOU HAD SOM
OFHEAME THREATSUSHBK
OUT TAIN KNOW?
>> YEAHE'D BIG CRISND6
PRIDENT CLTON NT TO U.
AWNE SUPPORTED HIMHE
INES DICTATORSP INVITED ME
SPEECH ISHANAI ANDEIJI.
TOLD HIM THA WE WERE TGO
TAIN AND HE WENT CRA.
IS IT O YAN'T DO IT, YCAN'T DOTF
YOU ELHATTRONGLY WILL IP
INA D JUST GO TO TAIN S
WITH THE COMPRISE WAS I FLEFROMN
OM JAPANO TAIN SOE
DIDN SOROF RUB TIR FES
AND IT BUT THINK
SPEAR NANCY PELOSIAS NO
CHCE N THAT IT'S OUTN THE
OPEN ANDHAT THEHINE
COUNIS ARE DANCING AROD
AND MINGHREA AND ALL TT,
E HAS TO GO TAIWA.
BACK DOWN NOULD ENCRAGE
EVERAGGRSIVE BULLYINATTITUDEF TI
INK WOULD BE AISASR.
M HONG THE NEXT DAYR SO
WHERCAN A SEER I TAIN I
FRANY THINK AT T CHINESE
COMMISTS WILL THEN CALM WN.
THEYE RUING A BLUFF.
THE CT IS THA THERE NOT
GONNA TAKE  THE UNITED STATES
THAT CANAKE OUT SPEAK OF
THE HOU.
NONSENSE AND IANAPPES ARE
>>anni: I THEY DIDRE
THEY BASICALLY STAING
WORLD R II
TH'RE REATENING TO OOT
WOULD BE LITERLY AACT OFAT
R.
WOU HAVE N CHOICE EXCT
TO RETELOR RALIATE
SSIVY.
OPLEEND TOORGETHE.S.
DEITE THE AKNE OF THE
PENTON,ESPITE ALL THE TRUWOKE S.
WE STILL HAVE A PERFUL
MILITARY.
WITH OUR AIESN AUSTRALIA,JAN, AY
FASTIFHEY CAN EORT, THEY STATO .
THEIR CITY HAS O EMPYMENT.
IF TY C'T IMPORTHEYEGIN
THETART
E CHINESERE N NECESRILY
IN ATRONG POSITIOTO T TO
BULL UI INKE NEED TO RECOGNI
THAT A IT' RLLY IMPORTANT
WHEN YOU'RDEALG WITH T
CTATSHIP TO STANDP T THEM
AND MAKE THEM REALIZEHAT
LIMITS TWHATHEY CANRE REAL
COMPSH.
WHO KNOWS PSYOLOGICAL WHA
THOULD CCLUDE WTHERR
T TH WOULD THEN DIDE
PU IS EN FURER B TRY AND
OCCUPYAIWAN.>> Hanni: TY'RE CALI
TH INFTION REDUCTI ACT
TO G HAMRED AT A TIM WHEN
AST AFFO FORT WITH HIGHERTAXES.
LY WASHINGTON,.C.,AN CL
METHG JUST THE OPPOSE O
WHAT IT IS.
BUT THATS WH THEY'RERYIN
I DON'T KNOIT'LL HU THE PPLE OF
ST VIRGINIA, BUTOWS WHAT
IN THE REDTION ACTT TH
SCHOOL OF BINES AND
CONGSSIONAL BUDGE COMTTEES
AR SAYING  WILDO NOUCH
WE WON'TEDUC INFLATION IT'RE-IN.
>> IAN'T FIGE O WHY HE
WOUL HAV APPVED A BILL WHICH
RAISES TAX ONOAL DIRTLY
HITTG WT VIRGINIA.
THE GHOSTF FURTH THIACT IS
ANNTIRELLY.
IS VY PRD OF T WEEND THE
HERSEL WALKER RUN R T
SETEN GEORG CHAENGE
SENATOR WARN OFFAS VERY
ARTILATE PREACHER L TH
STF.
SAI TO HIMHY D'T IN
AUST HAVE A DEBE ON THI
BILLERE  PROMPTLY SAID NO
CHANCE HE'NOT NNA D IT
THGHT IT WAS FASCITINGND I
THINIT EVERY REPUBCAN
CANDATE IN TOUNTRY SHOULD
CHALLENGE THEIRPPONTO
FENDHAT I THINK ITHE TAX
INCRSE 87,000 MORENTERL
RETIL AGENTS HIGR SNDING
GREATER ILATI BILL JUST WH
THIS RLLY .
TO TAKE CHAE TO P O IWANT
THINK THE SETE RUBLICANS
HAVE AN ABLUTE OBLIGATNO
E EVY PCEDUL PROCESS TO
STOPHIS LL FROM GETTING
VOTED ON THELOOR THE RECS OF
THISOUNTRY IS TO LK AT THIS
THERE ISO POSSIBILITYFWLDIE.
SENAR RUNNI FOREELECTION
ANDHE DOCRATIC PARTY NTS
PEOP BK HE JUST A SGLE
QUESON YOU REALLYHINKOU
NEED 87,000 RERS AGENTS?
THIS OY 7700 RIGHTOW.
THAT MORE THANOUBLG THE
NUMBER OF IR AGENTS.
M THK MARK CAN AFFORD THA
EVERYONE WILLET THEANNITY
TRTMENT.
EV OATCOUNTER TO ACCNTIN
FIS IN A LAW F